bonsoir voici les titres de l'actualité
de ce 29 avril les gendarmes mis en
examen pour la destruction d'un
restaurant près d'ajaccio resteront en
prison
l'anc est temps d'établir les mobiles de
l'action commando des gendarmes frappes
répétées de l'aviation de l'otan sur
belgrade et le monténégro nous serons en
direct de podgorica avec benoît duquesne
contacts diplomatiques à moscou
réclusion kofi annan secrétaire général
de l'onu monsieur hubert védrine
ministre des affaires étrangères est
notre invité les réfugiés rapportent des
récits dramatiques témoignage en albanie
avec l'autre sans père et enquête sur
les effets déstabilisateurs du conflit
en macédoine avec pascal douce est bon
quarante deux ans et demi de travail
pour partir en retraite le rapport remis
à lionel jospin déclenché des réactions
très diverses et l'on évoque à nouveau
les fonds de pension la france des
chasseurs condamnée par la cour
européenne il faudra revoir les
conditions d'exercice de la chasse non
loin les habitations l'olympique de
marseille handicapé avant la finale de
coupe d'europe christophe dugarry
suspendu pour 5 matches fermes près les
incidents entre joueurs de bologne et de
marseille lors de la demi-finale la
cinquième semaine du conflit engagé par
l'otan contre le régime serbe ressemble
aux semaines précédentes avec cependant
aujourd'hui des frappes intensives aussi
bien au kosovo qu'à belgrade et au
monténégro commenté françois corner
belgrade
01 47 la nuit dernière la dcn yougoslave
essaie de contrer enfin les vagues
d'assaut de l'aviation de l'otan qu'ils
bombarderont à trois reprises jusqu'à
4h30 5 ce matin les faubourgs de la
capitale yougoslave cible visée que nous
découvrons petit jour sur ces images de
la télévision serbe
les paraboles et les amateurs de la rts
des raids destiné justement à réduire au
silence le média national qui aimait
toujours l'otan dans sa rituelle
l'énumération de ces attaques
quotidiennes n'a fait aucun commentaire
aujourd'hui sur ce paradoxe
au cours de cette 36ème nuit de
bombardement la raffinerie de novi sad
en voïvodine a une nouvelle fois été
touché par deux missiles cet objectif
considéré comme stratégique par
l'alliance et bombarder régulièrement
il est possible que les frappes soit
dosé pour éviter de trop importantes
émanations de gaz toxiques dans la
destruction des cubes de ce complexe
chimique dans cette même région
ce pont enjambant la rivière saab a été
détruit il s'agit toujours pour l'otan
de couper les axes menant vers le sud
une autre cible la nuit dernière pour
les avions de l'otan symbolique celle ci
la ville natale de slobodan milosevic
pas j'aurai bac à une soixantaine de
kilomètres à l'est de belgrade ont fait
une nouvelle polémique dans ces raids
aériens avec l'égarement de ce missile
de l'otan qui s'est écrasé la nuit
dernière dans un faubourg de sofia en
bulgarie
les porte parole de l'alliance ont
d'abord déclaré que ce missile
n'appartenait pas à l'arsenal de l'otan
les ministres bulgare des affaires
étrangères et de l'intérieur affirme
être eu que ce missile armes est
habituellement tirés par les f16
américains de plus il précisé que la
nuit dernière un avion à des violet
l'espace aérien bulgare en entrant à
partir du kosovo et en ressortant en
direction de la macédoine
cette trajectoire exclu sur l'eau sofia
qu'il puisse s'agir d'un avion serbes
devant ces précisions irréfutable l'otan
admettez que ce missile lui appartenait
bien et qu'il avait dévié de sa cible un
radar anti aérien serbe au kosovo selon
l'ambassadeur de yougoslavie à moscou
qui est aussi le frère de slobodan
milosevic plus de 1000 civils ont été
tués et cinq mille autres blessées par
les bombardements de l'otan de son côté
l'état major yougoslave indiqué ce matin
belgrade que depuis le début du conflit
46 avions de l'otan avaient été abattus
chiffre évidemment invérifiable et
contesté par l'otan le bombardement du
monténégro a été justifiée par la
présence d'une partie de la force
aérienne serbe selon monsieur jospin
nos envoyés spéciaux benoît duquesne et
jean-françois renou ont pu détailler la
nature de quelques-unes des bombes
utilisées puisque vous êtes la
télévision française puisque vous êtes
un pays démocratique et si vous en avez
le courage montré avec quelle arme votre
pays se bat aujourd'hui nous sommes à
environ 3 km des aéroports civils et
militaires une zone de maisons
individuelles de jardin de prairies
truffé de cuisine
de petites bombes john moody de
parachute on dirait de gros aérosols
posait dans les jardins mais personne ne
sait trop bien quand elle explose ce que
l'on sait en revanche c'est qu'elles
font des dégâts
tu le bétail perforent les routes et
cribles d'éclat les maisons négocié son
fils et son petit-fils qui a 6 ans et
est ici quand les bombes ont commencé à
tomber
ils ont voulu se réfugier dans la maison
mais ça n'était pas possible
la voiture était en feu alors ils ont
fait demi tour et se sont cachés dans le
garage
c'était lors du premier bombardement à
13 heures hier les gens ont vu un avion
largué trois à cinq cents de ces petites
bombes après avoir bombardé l'aéroport
les bons sont interdites par les
conventions internationales que respecte
en principe l'otan mais moi je suis
convaincu que ce n'est pas une erreur
que c'est fait exprès pour terroriser
les gens pour les soldats fédéraux qui
ont accepté que nous filmions ces images
c'est bien la preuve que l'otan utilise
des armes interdites contre les
populations civiles
pour les personnes que nous avons
rencontrées or la présence des
militaires
c'est tout simplement la preuve qu'elles
ne sont à l'abri nulle part frappes
chirurgicales ou pas ici c'est l'un des
fils qui a été légèrement blessé quand
ça s'est produit j'étais dans la maison
j'ai voulu sortir mais je ne sais pas où
aller tout était en flammes
on s'est vraiment affreux vous savez
c'est presque millan comme sentiment
c'est une catastrophe une immense
catastrophe
la seule victime des bombardements
d'hier et de cette nuit est une femme de
61 ans
elle habitait près de la base militaire
de tutsis quand les avions sont arrivés
n'a pas eu le temps de se mettre à
l'abri
benoît duquesne vous êtes à podgorica
qu'avez vous pu constater sur place des
dégâts causés par les derniers
bombardements
écoutez évidemment les dégâts qu'ils
étaient j'imagine visé par le par l'otan
cela bien sûr on n'a pas pu les
constater puisqu'il concerne l'aéroport
lui-même airport civils ou militaires
qui sont bien sûr
zone interdite il est pas question du
tout faits militaires nous laisse
accéder à ces zones là en revanche nous
sommes retrouvés un petit peu par hasard
parce qu'on savait qu'un jeune homme
avait été blessé à 2,3 kilomètres de cet
aéroport comme on l'a vu dans le
reportage et nous sommes tombés sur des
militaires et après deux heures trois
heures de négociations ce qui est très
rare ici à mon avis la première fois ils
ont accepté que nous filmions ce que
nous avons filmé ils n'ont pas accepté
bien sûr qu'on les films eux-mêmes il
conte les interviews qu on leur demande
leur avis et ils l'ont fait pourquoi il
met tout simplement parce qu'ils sont je
pense pour la plupart convaincu que les
armes qu'ils ont vu notamment ces
petites bombes qui s'était fait pas
forcément déclenché qui est pas exposés
étaient en fait les bombes anti
personnel interdit par les conventions
internationales les c'était pour eux la
preuve que l'otan utilisé des bombes
interdites
d'après nos informations ce n'est pas le
cas ce sont des bombes bien au type anti
matériel qui servent quand on attaque
comme ça un aéroport le problème c'est
qu'elles sont tombés là où elle devait
pas tomber c'est à dire à trois
kilomètres de l'aéroport et que les gens
que ce soit les civils ou quelquefois
les militaires en tout cas les civils
sont convaincus qu'il s'agit bien de
frappe interdite merci venant ce soir
après cette édition le magazine envoyé
spécial proposera notamment le reportage
réalisé à belgrade par jacques merino
reportages sur la vie quotidienne
pendant les bombardements
voici un extrait il s'agit d'une famille
plutôt francophile qui témoigne de son
incompréhension devant le conflit elle
travaille dans une société
d'import-export lui est ingénieur
ils sont là avec un couple d'amis 20g
attendre qu'elle avait de cesse on
n'entendait pas quelque chose comme ça
de la part de la civilisation européenne
occidentale une solution komba
bombardements lundi sans déclaration de
guerre qui ne pas déclarer la guerre à
quelqu'un qui n'ait pas repris
l'autre terre envahie à notre pays un
quelque chose que une angine
parce que nous sommes comme une bombe à
des peurs par nos alliés c'est comme une
punition quand vous punissez un petit
enfant
on n'a pas la possibilité de bié son
opinion et quand éclate les premiers
tirs de décès à c'est presque un
soulagement
le sentiment idiot de retrouver une
normalité
peut-être parce que à ce moment là on a
cessé d'attendre il on peut s'occuper à
regarder c'est clair dans le ciel où
7000 à ce point lumineux missile
américain thomas o a battu par un autre
missile courtage ce soir dans envoyé
spécial activité diplomatique par et
retrouver des forces et d'une part le
déplacement de monsieur kofi annan le
secrétaire général de l'onu à moscou et
le voyage de victor tchernomirdine
l'envoyé spécial du président eltsine à
rome bonne puis belgrade dans les 48
heures qui viennent
de plus monsieur tchernomirdine affirme
avoir des propositions concrètes à faire
correspondance à moscou gilles rabin et
franck brisset
quand on convoque une conférence de
presse alors qu'on a rien à dire autant
s'y mettra cap au tour de rihanna de
secrétaire général des nations unies le
chef de la diplomatie russe igor ivanov
avait réuni le ministre des affaires
étrangères de pays membres de l'otan et
le canadien lol sophie c'est le grec
georges papandréou
dès les premiers mots de kofi annan qui
n'est pas très bien considéré à moscou
où on le tient pour responsable du
déclin actuel de l'onu on comprend qu'il
n'a rien de nouveau à annoncer le
canadien évoquera sans préciser un
accord sur des bases objectives une
solution qui reste encore à trouver le
grec rappellera que son pays est à la
fois proche des serbes membres de
l'union européenne et membre de l'otan
contre les bombes et contre milosevic et
que ces contradictions peuvent un jour
se révéler utile tout cela a fait un peu
tourner la tête à boris eltsine qui
hasard du calendrier recevait en plus
aujourd'hui
le sud africain nelson mandela qui
effectue en europe un voyage
dieu avant de se retirer de la politique
début juin nous admirons bien sûr la
façon dont vous mener les affaires en
yougoslavie aux huttes en afrique du sud
une seule télévision russe ntv la chaîne
privée à diffuser cet extrait sur les
autres et sur les images officielles
distribué par le kremlin
la séquence a été censuré boris elstine
n'était manifestement pas au mieux de sa
forme aujourd'hui il a grossi pokou et
en peu de temps
ces gestes semblent difficiles parfois
même douloureux je tient fermement
debout a confié à son visiteur
même les communistes ne me renverseront
pas ma santé est solide il parlait bien
sûr de 500 policiers védrine bonsoir
plus que jamais vous pensez que la voie
diplomatique parce ferme à ce coup c'est
un élément très important mais il faut
pas tout ramener à 100 le travail
diplomatique d'ailleurs n'a jamais cessé
et dès le premier jour du moment nous
avons dû passer par l'emploi de la force
pour donner un coup d'arrêt à toute
cette politique qui depuis quelques
années est fait quand même deux cent
mille morts dans ces balkans en même
temps le travail diplomatique a été
poursuivie de deux façons avec nos
partenaires occidentaux pour préciser ce
que nous pouvons garder des accords de
rambouillet pour la solution du kosovo
demain et ce que nous devons pas rentrer
adapté et d'autre part avec les russes
et même au moment où là le discours us
était le plus dur par rapport à l'action
menée
nous avions des canaux de communication
les ministres ivanov convient de voir il
ya quelques instants parler à ses
homologues européens je les ai vus
souvent et nous avons tout de suite
commencé à réfléchir aux schémas de la
solution et c'est dès ce moment là que
nous la france notamment nous avons
insisté sur le fait qu'il fallait que le
moment venu ce soit le conseil de
sécurité ou à l'intérieur du conseil de
sécurité des pays membres qui édicte le
schéma de solutions dans son ensemble
d'accord vous parlez avec monsieur
ivanoff aimé monsieur primakov et
monsieur tchernomirdine sont déjà les
avais grade résultat néant
malheureusement ils n'ont eu aucun
résultat en effet mais ça ne veut pas
dire que leurs efforts doivent cesser
nous les encourageons à persévérer à
poursuivre je ne sais pas ce que
monsieur tchernomyrdine a comme une
éventuelle éléments nouveaux ce que je
sais c'est grave et des intérêts ou la
non je ne sais pas encore là parce que
you
j'attends un coup de fil d'un long débat
localement et j'étais pas joignables
juste avant de venir
j'étais dans une autre une autre
émission juste avant de venir ici il
conviendra de france internationale
voilà donc je vais avoir des indications
tout à l'heure ce qui est important
c'est qu'il ya déjà eus ces derniers
jours une évolution de la position russe
qui s'est rapproché de notre position
est qu'ils acceptent de plus en plus
l'idée d'une résolution du conseil de
sécurité comportant une force
internationale au sol mais belgrade n'a
pas évolué puisque on a vu que draskovic
était une
c'était une carrosserie réellement vous
avez pensé que c'était une carte
diplomatique a joué dans verdun non s'il
s'agissait pas de jouer la carte il
s'agissait de savoir si sa annoncé une
évolution des autorités de belgrade et
on a vu après que ce n'était pas le cas
que c'était simplement une jolie
individuel de monsieur draskovic et de
son parti à partir de laquelle se
développera peut-être une opposition
peut être une alternative mais en tout
cas aujourd'hui par généraliste à la
nonciature ya pas beaucoup de positions
oui peut pas y en avoir normalement sauf
si c'est une dictature qui perd quand
même progressivement ses moyens de
répression et de terreur tous les jours
parce croyais expliqua bien sûr donc
techniquement c'est pas vrai qu'ils sont
affaiblis actuels 1 ils sont
militairement affaiblissent a fait aucun
doute
on se rapproche chaque jour du moment où
cette armée sera paralysé mais ça vous
le disiez il ya déjà trois semaines
oui et j'en passe on dirait sont à fait
blancs et ça va durer longtemps
je ne sais pas vous savez au début la
plupart des experts ont fait des
analyses un peu optimiste sur la durée
maintenant faut pas tomber dans l'excès
inverse
en réalité il faut raccorder ça
l'objectif est non pas une durée près
d'albi les réservations repas peut pas
douter du fait que tous les jours cette
capacité de le répression est de plus en
plus affaibli parce qu'ils ont du mal à
se coordonner a communiqué que les
matériels détruits sont de plus en plus
nombreux que les transports sont
difficiles donc la capacité de nuire de
cette armée plus en plus faible
l'opération du chanteur également la
sortie change joliment chancelier
allemand gerhard schröder relance une
proposition de pause dans les
bombardements de l'otan
ça c'est pas les actions qu'il y ait des
signes et vérifiable de la mres un
retrait mais comment vérifier il
faudrait d'abord envoyé une force
d'interposition est une force de gauche
allié fraudeurs justement après
l'entretien après avec l'envoyé russe a
rappelé plusieurs choses
l'arrêt des meurtres le début du retour
des réfugiés
le retrait le début du rotary lie à ce
moment là on pourrait envisager une
pause je crois que tous les avis serait
d'accord pour l'envisager
à ce moment là
et on n'a pas ces éléments vous pensez
qu'on n'est pas ce moment là et nous
n'avons pas de l'arrêt des exactions au
kosovo il faut en arriver riz fiable par
satellite et au sol
si les russes par rim disait mandat
obtenu qu'un tel moment tout s'arrête au
kosovo et qu'on puisse envoyer des
observateurs pour le vérifier ce serait
le début de quelque chose ça n'est pas
le cas aujourd'hui
je n'ai pas l'impression que ce soit
encore le cas en tout cas là c'est pour
indiquer que la proposition de pose du
chancelier schröder est à tapoter dans
ce contexte c'est s'il y avait des
éléments nouveaux vérifiable sur tous
ces plans on les a pas encore mais ça
n'empêche pas qu'il faille travailler
d'arrache-pied pour avoir une solution
politique prête le moment venu et qu'à
ce moment puisse aller très vite
alors depuis le début de cette semaine
des témoignages concordants semble être
recueilli par les observateurs du haut
commissariat aux réfugiés sur des
massacres des exécutions john holmes ou
encore de viols commis au kosovo par des
milices serbes
le dernier afflux de réfugiés d'albanais
du kosovo au poste frontière de maureen
a apporté également depuis hier des
récits d'horreur reportage de nos
envoyés spéciaux près de la frontière de
l'albanie du kosovo claude samper et
bernie nerio ils vont essayer de
retrouver un peu de calme et de paix
tous ces réfugiés arrivés hier de
plusieurs villages autour de djokovic à
racontent tous la même histoire celle de
plusieurs massacres de grande ampleur
commis par les forces serbes
mardi dernier entre 6 heures et 8 heures
du matin dans le village d'origine
étaient quinze ans que je sais par terre
les mains en sang ils étaient tous vos
propres yeux
oui de mes propres yeux j'ai même
compter les cadavres ont marché sur la
route on les a vus comme ils étaient
quinze personnes avec les mains comme ça
allongé par terre
combien ils ont rassemblés de jeunes
entre 300 et 500 qu'est ce qu'ils ont
fait quelques-uns qui disent qu'ils ont
été égorgés mais nous on était séparés
d'eux on ne sait pas tout les médecins
qui ont accueilli six réfugiés hier ont
noté des traumatismes profonds
ils ont été frappés par l'état
psychologique de ces personnes qui
racontait presque avec les mêmes mots
des meurtres et des exécutions
collectives
est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous pouvez dire
que vous êtes sûr qu'un massacre a été
commis dans la région djakovica hier
écoutez c'est très très difficile de
dire vraiment sûr mais il est bien sûr
que autant de témoignages qui concorde
qui sont tous ensemble nous permettre
quand même de dire que des massacres
étaient pas peut être lassé
c'est clair à chaque arrivée de réfugiés
des enquêteurs de différentes
organisations de défense des droits de
l'homme interroge les réfugiés pour
trouver des preuves des masses à jour en
est avocate elle questionne pendant des
heures les réfugiés et elle vient même
visionner les témoignages recueillis par
la presse aujourd'hui êtes-vous sûr que
plusieurs massacres ont eu lieu dans les
villages autour de jeff kolodjay
chaque show non on n'est pas sûr qu'on
ne sera précisément ce qui s'est passé
que lorsqu'on aura terminé notre travail
très non nos interviews pour recueillir
avec précision et détaille tous les
frais pour tous les camps de réfugiés au
nord de l'albanie il y a seulement deux
enquêteurs officiels du tpiy le tribunal
pénal international
aujourd'hui la présidente de ce tribunal
louise arbour demande plus d'hommes plus
de moyens pour faire ce travail très
lent de vérification des témoignages les
arbres on sait qu'il lui faudra des
preuves solides pour faire un jour
peut-être juger les responsables de ces
massacres et les faire condamner pour
crime contre l'humanité et madame à
rebours sera la semaine prochaine paris
où il rencontrera le président le chef
du gouvernement
en macédoine la tension est très vive
entre réfugiés albanais et une grande
partie de la population macédonienne
d'origine slave l'afflux des réfugiés a
modifié l' équilibre d origine
la macédoine compte aujourd'hui 30 %
d'albanophones pour 60% de personnes
parlant le serbo croate
la macédoine est un pays dont
l'indépendance remonte à 1991 et son
unité est encore fragile une équipe de
france 2 avec pascal de ces bons
emmanuel butty philippe lozzi enquêtait
sur ce déséquilibre des populations
enquête menée chez les jeunes dans les
milieux universitaires les plus opposés
parfois unités multilinguisme multi
ethnicisme les cours de conversation
française de la faculté de skopje ne
traite que de ça depuis le début des
princes
ces étudiantes avait trois ou quatre ans
à la mort de tito
mais la guerre au kosovo a fait renaître
leur nostalgie yougoslave
on était tous suivre slave on a parlé
pas je suis macédonien je suis croître
je suis serbe je suis je sais pas quoi
je suis albanais on était tous
yougoslavie avait pas de problème de
nationalité allemande
comment ça con s'il ya des choses dont
on ne pensait pas et les appels dans la
mauvais sens propre une démo lundi les
étudiants de skopje sont en majorité
slave
ils disent avoir peur du repli
communautaire et affichent leur volonté
d'union mais lorsque l'étranger s'étonne
que l'albanais est parlé par 30% de la
population soit enseigné ici comme une
langue parmi d'autres sa question est
tout de suite jugé provocant
est ce qu'en france il ya universités à
l'albanie et qu'il y ait une identité un
algérien il y à beaucoup de sagesse et à
la base il ya beaucoup de gens de
d'afrique
j'ai vu là-bas j'étais enfant donc voilà
la position et la réponse alors 40 km de
skopje l'intelligentsia albanaise a créé
sa propre université
heureusement pour le visiteur elle est
signalée par des enseignes
sans cela le campus de tetovo serait
bien difficile à identifier ici la
faculté n'est pas reconnue et donc pas
financée par skopje
elle se débrouille avec les moyens du
bord alors évidemment le discours
estudiantin n'a pas grand chose à voir
avec celui de la capitale vous avez des
amis macédonien d'avoir la réalité donc
là vous voyez vous voyez où nous apprend
c'est terrible
vous êtes de la même nationalité vous
avez le même passeport mais pour moi
n'est pas important mon passeport
mais pour moi je porte en moi de quoi
inquiéter les macédoniens slave qui voit
ici un nid de nationalistes albanais est
un facteur de ghettoïsation du pays
le président de l'université lui à une
tout autre idée sur la question
la stratégie si j'ose dire cela en tout
cas les macédoniens sont des slaves
c'est toujours que dans tous les
endroits où vivent les albanais qui le
peuvent les tenir moins instruits moins
enseignées - dans tous les domaines les
élites politiques elles font tout pour
gommer ce genre d'antagonisme le pouvoir
est partagé entre le principal parti
slave qui dirige le gouvernement et cinq
ministres du parti démocratique albanais
proche de loucher cas qui font pas de
velours
depuis les premières frappes de l'otan
aujourd'hui le dialogue ma seule donnée
à l'albanaise on va aller chapitre par
chapitre voile que
on se dérange pas dans nos différents
espaces et qu'on puisse vivre ensemble
autrement dit le pda fera tout pour ne
pas gêner le premier ministre slave qui
ne nie pas les risques d'explosion du
pays bien sûr cette crise réveille les
patients ici c'était la coalition
gouvernementale de faire face mais c'est
aussi la responsabilité de la communauté
internationale
sinon le désordre s'étendre à tous les
balkans et vidosevic aura atteint son
but
c'est ce langage que tiendra le jeune
premier ministre demain face à lionel
jospin les bonnes volontés ne suffiront
peut-être plus à maintenir l'équilibré
du pays c'est la vie ici des
albanophones comme des slaves
c'est la situation au kosovo et rien
d'autre qui déterminera l'avenir
politique du pays
bien vivre et nous avons entendu ce
témoignage de jeune fille qu'ils aient
yougoslavie on vivait tous ensemble tous
maintenant tout est déstabilisé on soit
connaît plus on se méfie est-ce que nous
ne sommes pas un peu responsable aussi
de ses conséquences auprès des
populations qui vivaient auparavant ce
ses reportages très intéressante
m'inspire des réactions suivant d'abord
tito était un génie et je crois qu'on
s'en aperçoive beaucoup plus de force et
que le recul qu'il avait réussi à
fédérer tout ça oui
deuxièmement on peux absolument pas dire
que la france soit responsable en quoi
que ce soit la france à partir des
années 80 11 a tout fait pour encadrer
canaliser ralentir pour mieux géré la
désintégration de la yougoslavie
les faire en sorte que les questions de
frontières et de minorité soit traitée
suffisamment tôt la france
malheureusement mais l'europe
bon désolé l'europe à l'avant pour la
prendre conscience de ces problèmes là
avant d'aller bombarder
non non vous parlez de 99 moi je parle
de la jeunesse de ça parce que la
yougoslavie cette nostalgie qui
réapparaît qu'on peut comprendre ça
remonte à 91 90 81 ans quand les choses
se sont disloqués la france a fait tout
ce qu'elle a pu à l'époque
malheureusement les américains les
différents européens les russes
n'étaient pas sur la même ligne à
l'époque et les différents responsables
des différentes nationalité yougoslave
ont tous une carte nationaliste
naturellement la responsable des
premières et celles du présent ii s'est
vite mais malheureusement il ya une
fuite en avant dans le nationalisme
partout et on en voit les résultats
rebondissements y compris sur les élèves
oh quel est l'avenir après la guerre
vous avez raison c'est ça le sujet ça
veut dire qu'aujourd'hui au delà de la
question du kosovo elle nous avons parlé
de la solution politique pour le kosovo
savoir une vision d'ensemble pour que
ces gens que nous voulions tous autant
qu'ils soient c'est à dire aussi bien
les serbes que les albanais du kosovo
les différents macédonien l'édifiante
une population de la beauce nîmes des
croates aussi les bulgares et les
roumains fattouche il faut qu'ils
arrivent à avoir un projet d'ensemble
pour les balkans de demain et de l'union
européenne a une responsabilité
historique sur ce point il faut les
sortir de ce cycle séculaire de la
vengeance de la haine de la peur et de
cet enfermement sans fin il faut les
aider à bâtir ensemble une partie de
leur situation sociale reste sous quelle
forme lui avait cependant dû fédération
est ce que c'est par exemple la
partition du kosovo
c'est toute la feuille c'est un sujet
quitte pas et qui n'est pas ça sera une
autonomie ou une indépendance l'exemple
au kosovo c'est l'autonomie je contrôle
international et pas la défiance
non personne retient la solution
d'indépendance parce que précisément
saffré cycle s'écrouler comme un château
de cartes tout le reste du système
l'albanie le monténégro et la macédoine
celle inverse ce qu'il faut faire il
faut accompagner ces différentes
populations des différents pays des
différents gouvernements dans la
démocratisation dans le développement
parce qu'un poème de pauvreté derrière
tout ça si et d'autre part en matière de
sécurité pour qu'ils arrêtent de
terroriser par le voisin de penser que
dès qu'ils sont minoritaires ils seront
massacrés ce qui était le cas très
souvent c'est une histoire tragique
depuis des siècles et des siècles le 20e
siècle a été tragique la seconde guerre
mondiale était atroce par rapport à
cette cette région du monde
la yougoslavie je le disais grâce au
génie de tito a été un moment suspendues
entre tout ça ça recommençait qu une
violence accrue depuis la dislocation de
la yougoslavie et la résurgence du
nationalisme dans sa forme la plus
brutale notre rôle à nous en dans
l'union européenne des pays occidentaux
c'est de faire tout ce que nous pouvons
pour le développement la stabilité la
sécurité de l'ensemble des pays et des
peuples des balkans pour qu'ils arrivent
comme les gens d'europe occidentale a
considéré que c'est vraiment absolument
absurde et tragique de s'entretuer pour
ces questions et qu'ils ont une entité
régionale elle peut enfermer ces pannes
ou la dictée non plus c'est travailler
avec eux peut-être qu'il faut qu'on
fasse une conférence c'est un projet qui
a été adopté par l'union européenne le
14 avril
une conférence sur l'avenir des balkans
il faut qu'on la prépare bien et qu'on
regarde le rôle de l'union européenne de
l'otan de l'eau et ceux de la banque
mondiale on arrive à coordonner
l'ensemble des actions et qu'on traite
bien même temps chaque cas particulier
de son temps de cas particuliers mais
quand vous me demandiez son travail et
sur la solution diplomatique
on travaille aussi à ça parce qu'on
n'arrivera pas réglé kosovo
réintégration de la yougoslavie
démocratiser dans l'europe de demain si
en même temps on n'a pas cette vision
très forte sur l'européanisation des
balkans pour que les balkans devienne
comme nous un jour ces femmes but merci
monsieur védrine dès la fin de cette
semaine un premier rapport de l' enquête
administrative sur les conditions de
l'incendié d'une paillote sur une plage
corse près d'ajaccio sera remis au
ministre jean pierre chevènement je
pense qu'il y à beaucoup de gens qui ont
intérêt à créer des pataquès dynamisme
et le pataquès est déjà là puisque les
gendarmes mis en examen dont un colonel
comparaissait pour trois d'entre eux
devant le juge d'instruction d'ajaccio
le juge a déjà décidé le maintien en
détention de deux d'entre eux compte
rendu
olivier théron et diane richard citons
falcon 900 que le colonel mazères le
lieutenant tavernier il a dû dans chef
moulié sont arrivés ajaccio à la mi
journée direction le palais de justice
sous escorte dans trois voitures
différentes
le visage dissimulé ils sont passés à
tour de rôle dans le cabinet du juge
cambérou qui a décidé leur maintien en
détention
après le débat contradictoire le colonel
mazères le patron du gps se serait rendu
deux fois la direction de la gendarmerie
à paris pour évoquer la situation c'est
là qu'on lui a demandé lundi de se
mettre à la disposition de la justice
son avocat mario stasi a réaffirmé que
le colonel niait toute implication dans
l'incendié criminel seules commentaires
éviter les dérives dans ce dossier
signaler et je regrette sincèrement que
ce mail
un débat qui devrait être purement
judiciaire des éléments qui ne le sont
pas
je comprends l'émotion de l'opinion
publique je déplore les exploitations
politiques qui peuvent être faites d'un
côté comme de l'autre pour la seule
raison non pas parce qu'elles existent
mais parce qu'elles peuvent être un
obstacle à la sérénité de la justice
l'avocat des autres armées manuel santos
tient lui aussi à réaffirmer leur
innocence
il défend la thèse de l'embuscade je
crois qu'en fait c'est un concours de
circonstances et il y a eu des oui
maintenant ils sont trouvés dans un
traquenard comme je l'aï déjà dit et en
conséquence de quoi il y a eu blessure
de son côté îles féroe le patron de la
paillote s'est constituée partie civile
ce matin son avocat veut que l' enquête
remonte aux hypothétiques donneurs
d'ordre comme nous essayons de nous
demandons simplement à ce que la justice
ne nous entraîne au véritable degré de
la responsabilité de cette affaire et ne
nous maintiennent pas un degré
intermédiaire les trois gendarmes dès le
débat contradictoire terminé sont
repartis direction la prison de la santé
à paris et l'ancien ministre de
l'intérieur monsieur charles pasqua
nuance les critiques de l'opposition il
estime que certains sont allés un peu
vite dans leurs critiques à l'égard des
gendarmes corse il est vrai que
l'opération commando menée par ses
hommes du groupe de pelotons de sécurité
n'est pas très clair reportage michèle
fines et france voyant 9 avril 99
le préfet bonnet on voit les engins du
génie militaire à l'assaut des paillotes
le représentant de l'état en corse a
décidé de raser ses restaurants de
constructions précaires bâti à même la
plage sur le domaine public maritime et
sans permis de construire
c'est ce que l'on va appeler la guerre
des paillotes d'un côté en première
ligne les gendarmes de l'autre les
propriétaires des restaurants y ferro
patron de chez francis et que l'on voit
ici à droite est l'un des plus actifs
très vite les élus se range du côté des
patrons de paillotes tous partis
confondus nationaliste gauche droite
ils ont même un soutien inattendu celui
de françois léotard en vacances sur
l'île ce scandaleux ce qui se ressemble
s'assemble élections
si vous voulez fabriquer des
nationalistes y a qu'à continuer comme
ça le jour bam
les élus corses eux sont reçus à la
préfecture d'ajaccio ils en sortent
satisfaits mais en narbonnais a accepté
de laisser aux propriétaires des
paillotes un sursis de six mois
ils pourront donc ouvrir pendant la
saison d'été certains voient dans cette
concession une reculade du préfet les
gendarmes ont ils étaient déçus par
cette décision au point d'imaginer un
acte de vengeance
voulait-il plus simplement semer la
zizanie entre les propriétaires des
paillotes
c'est l'une des hypothèses de l'anc est
la deuxième hypothèse c'est la guerre
des polices
au milieu des décombres les enquêteurs
ont découvert ce tract sert aux balances
des flics
balance défi travaux avec ses plus que
mettre le feu parce que ça c'est
vraiment atteindre leur personne et mon
honneur parce que je serais plutôt prêt
à faire la guerre ce d'aller prévenir
quelqu'un les gendarmes arrivent que
faire l' inverse
selon plusieurs sources les
renseignements généraux serait intervenu
auprès du préfet pour éviter la
destruction de la paillote di ferro
certains gendarmes notamment au gps
n'aime pas beaucoup les rg
pendant des mois les deux unités ont été
en concurrence dans l'enquêté rignac
lincendie de la paillote n'est-il que le
dernier épisode de l'affrontement police
gendarmerie en corse hypothèses ont
séduit beaucoup à l'assemblée de corse
aujourd'hui une motion était votée
demandant au gouvernement de faire toute
la lumière sur cette histoire mais ce
sont les nationalistes qui ont donné le
ton en citant des faits non élucidée de
plasticages ou d'assassinât et en
affirmant que la corse est un terrain
privilégié pour les coups tordus fin de
citation reportage jacques cardoze
vincent des ombres
même le président a du mal à s'y
retrouver deux amendements et un
sous-amendement pour une bataille de
verbes qui va durer une bonne heure
ainsi va l'après midi ponctué de
désaccord il s'agissait de voter une
motion mais la rédaction du texte a
souligné encore un peu plus les
divergences et nationaliste souhaitant
s'y remettre en cause intégralement la
politique menée dans l'île à l'opposé la
gauche plurielle préfère condamnés
seulement les méthodes
une divergence logique lorsque l'on
entend le discours du groupe
nationaliste qu'ils accusent l'état de
violence qui ont des styles officiers
aujourd'hui mais malgré l'incendié de la
paillote la politique du gouvernement
est encore soutenu par certains élus
insulaires de gauche même si elle est
ici minoritaires à l'image du vote de
cet après midi la motion ayant été
adoptées sans les voix de la gauche
plurielle
le rapport sur les retraites préparée
par le commissaire au plan monsieur jean
michel charpin a été officiellement
remis au premier ministre ce n'est pas
un plan de réforme mais juste un
aiguillon selon son auteur qui prône
l'allongement 42 ans et demi de la
période de cotisation pour tous les
régimes de retraite explications emilie
lançant j'en web ou sert à quel âge
prendrons-nous retraite demain le
système par répartition adoptée en 1945
est aujourd'hui fragilisée l'espérance
de vie ne cesse de croître
et d'ici 2005 les générations de
l'après-guerre vont arrivées à l'âge de
la retraite alors que le nombre d'actifs
lui continue à baisser dans 40 ans il y
aura sept retraités pour 10 actifs les
caisses de retraite seront ruinés dans
son rapport remis aujourd'hui à lionel
jospin jean michel charpin prévoit que
si rien n'est fait le déficit du régime
général de retraite sera de 403
milliards de francs en 2040 pour un taux
de chômage de 9%
un déficit qui se réduirait bien sûr si
le chômage venaient à baisser pour
éviter que ces projections ne devienne
une réalité
le commissaire au plan propose
d'allonger la durée de cotisation
progressivement en 2019 tout le monde
cotiseraient 42 ans et demi au lieu de
37 ans et demi actuellement dans le
public et 40 ans dans le privé
d'autres pistes sont avancées pas un mot
en revanche dans le rapport sur les
fonds de pension qui permettent de se
constituer une épargne individuelle
lionel josse parmi est pas totalement
opposée pour autant mais à condition que
l'avenir des retraites par répartition
soit au préalable garantie et que les
partenaires sociaux participent elles
gestion de ces faux les réactions sont
vives et diverses après la remise de ce
rapport je vous en cite deux pour le rpr
monsieur devedjian député il exprime sa
grande inquiétude et puis pour monsieur
blondel de force ouvrière le premier
ministre semble faire preuve de prudence
en voici d'autres maintenant avec les
commentaires de laurent bailly joseph
baltique
eh bien ce n'est pourtant pas le moment
parce que sur la question le
gouvernement a encore beaucoup à faire
les retraites un dossier tellement
sensible que lionel jospin a choisi de
communiquer par écrit sur le sujet et
pour dire quoi que la précipitation
serait une erreur les problèmes ne se
posent en qu'à partir de 2005 nous avons
le temps conclut-il et du temps il en
faudra pour concilier les points de vue
sur la durée de cotisation qui passerait
à 42 ans et demi la cgt par exemple
n'exclut pas un conflit social c'est un
dossier effectivement sensible alors
coeur d'affrontements pas encore et il
n'y a pas de raison de le pronostic est
comme tel ce que nous voulons vérifier
c'est que le gouvernement n'entend pas
reprendre à son compte
en l'état les conclusions du rapport
charpin un rapport exagérément alarmiste
jeu certains plus radicaux encore
s'appuie sur des données démographiques
tronquée partiel ces conclusions
amènerait à une régression sociale en
matière de retraite et à un
accroissement du chômage puisqu'il
prévoit essentiellement d'augmenter la
durée de travail en décalant l'âge de la
retraite alors adieu la retraite à 60
ans
tant pis dit la cfdt si ça permet de
sauvegarder les retraites par
répartition c'est garantir pour demain
le contrat des générations entre les
jeunes et les moins jeunes
c'est garantir que notre système de
protection sociale restera un choix
collectif et de société que la france ne
sera pas renvoyé à chacun qui devrait se
débrouiller pour trouver ces protections
demain mais au contraire il faut
développer l'épargné individuelle clame
le patronat et allonger la durée de
cotisation à 45 ans ça veut dire qu'on
travaillera jusqu'à 66 ans en 2020
bon je ne vois pas ce qu'il y a deux
particulièrement stupéfiants à le dire
parce que c'est vrai le rapport de jean
michel charpin un cadeau empoisonné donc
pour matignon qui ne prendra les
premières décisions qu à la fin de
l'année après avoir soigneusement
écouter tout le monde
le mouvement de grève se poursuit à la
sncf avec des suppressions de trains en
banlieue parisienne et sur les lignes du
nord et de l'est de la france mais le
trafic tgv devrait être assuré
normalement demain à air france un appel
à la grève a été lancé pour demain à
orly la grève des personnels au sol
pourrait entraîner quelques
perturbations tandis qu'à nice selon le
président d'air france tous les éléments
sont désormais réunies pour parvenir à
un accord
publication des résultats financiers de
la poste le résultat net en 98 a été
multiplié par six par rapport à 97
bénéfice net de 337 millions de francs
la cour européenne des droits de l'homme
à strasbourg a condamné la france pour
la loi dite verdet du nom de son auteur
loi qui oblige les petits propriétaires
a autorisé les chasseurs à traverser
leurs terres dix propriétaires avaient
ainsi protester contre la chasse et sa
réglementation française il faudra donc
revoir les privilèges des chasseurs
enquêtes et les vergnes et à la location
voici le document qui a donné raison aux
opposants à la chasse et fait tomber la
loi verdeille voter en 1964 ce texte
oblige les petits propriétaires à mettre
leurs terres à disposition du chasseur
c'est contraire au droit à la propriété
et à la liberté d'association a
notamment conclu la cour européenne des
droits de l'homme est à français devra
verser 30 mille francs à chacun des
plaignants
c'est un véritable revers pour les
chasseurs qui s'inquiètent des
conséquences de cette décision
si si le droit de propriété tellement
absolue que
on ne peut même pas y toucher pour dire
aux gens vont pas il faut organiser
ensemble la gestion de la chasse ça va
être plus lisible à la protection de la
nature qu utile aussi pour les
protecteurs de la nature c'est une
véritable satisfaction
un soulagement pour ce couple de haute
vienne malmené par des chasseurs tout
près de leur maison
s'il ya un danger ils ont une arme à feu
dans les mains ils ont suffisamment de
place pour chasser au loin sans venir
près de la maison
si les associations de fès ne sont pas
directement menacées par les décisions
européennes
désormais les propriétaires seront
libres de gérer leur serre nous voulons
que les gens aient la liberté d'opter
soit pour la chasse s'ils sont pour soi
pour la protection de la nature
s'ils sont adhérents des associations de
préservation des animaux sauvages et
qu'ils puissent constituer des refuges
politiquement les écologistes remportent
une nouvelle victoire sur le lobby de la
chasse mais déplore ce passage en force
on a regretté toujours qu'on refuse de
réformer cette fois aujourd'hui elle
tombe tout seul a quotas décision alors
qu'on aurait pu la modifier la mettre en
conformité avec le droit européen et
trouver des solutions des compromis qui
s'en vont pas tible entre avec les
droits des uns et les autres en
attendant une modification de la loi
verdeille c'est sur le terrain que
devront s'organiser de nouvelles
relations entre chasseurs et
propriétaires
d'autant que ni le gouvernement ni les
fédérations ne peuvent contester une
décision européenne du sport du football
enfin presque les incidents qui ont
suivi la demi finale marseille bologne à
bologne n'ont été sanctionné par la
fédération européenne et christophe
dugarry écope de cinq matches de
suspension et ne pourra donc pas jouer
la finale contre parme de plus mauvaise
journée pour l'om dans le directeur
général a préféré démissionner sous la
pression des supporters
l'explication florent gautreau avec
jean-françois giorgetti c'est ce qui
s'appelle une défaite de l'om sur
terrain neutre
réunis tout l'après midi à genève la
commission de discipline de l'union
européenne de football a pris des
sanctions exemplaires après les
incidents du match bologne marseille
christophe dugarry ne jouera pas la
finale
christophe dugarry et hamada jambay ont
été suspendus christophe dugarry pour
cinq matches et hamada jambay pour
quatre matches on ne saura jamais qui a
vraiment commencé mais les images que la
commission a visionné ont condamné
dugarry le joueur de l'équipe de france
affirmé avoir pris la défense d'un
coéquipier
argument rejeté par l'uefa qui a
suspendu également jambes et auteur d'un
coup de poing dans la mêlée pour leur
troisième finale de coupe d'europe
les marseillais seront donc privés de
cinq joueurs puisque ravanelli gallas et
luxin avait reçu un carton jaune à
bologne 3 joueurs italiens ont été
suspendus maigre consolation pour l'om
qui devra en outre payer 500 mille
francs d'amendé et pour rolland courbis
condamné lui à vingt mille francs
son fils stéphane courbis s'est vu
interdire toute fonction dans un club
pendant un an
l'om peut faire appel mais l'espoir est
mince dure journée pour le club déjà
ébranlée par la démission du président
délégué jean michel roussier les
supporters qui ne supportaient pas
l'autoritarisme de ce parisien descendu
à marseille réclamer son départ
depuis de longues semaines dure journée
pour les joueurs qui essaient de se
concentrer sur la fin du championnat les
boulots sous la marque et lui et j'ai
bien le foot ce sera ça demain les
marseillais retrouvent le terrain contre
lyon ils essaieront de gagner et
d'oublier l'espace d'un match toutes
leurs difficultés et pour finir une
bonne nouvelle pour le rugby mais aussi
pour france télévisions donc pour les
téléspectateurs que vous êtes qui
apprécient ce sport le comité directeur
de la fédération française de rugby a
reconduit pour deux ans et demi le
contrat liant la fédération à france
télévision qui diffusera donc quatorze
rencontres du quinze de france
commentaires christophe du chien
la marseillaise à pleins poumons le
grand frisson du spectacle rugbystique d
essai en bleu blanc rouge et le grand
chelem pourquoi pas le service public va
continuer de pouce en mêlée avec le
quinze de france
ainsi en a décidé le comité directeur de
la fédération française de rugby réuni
aujourd'hui à toulouse pour les trois
saisons à venir
france télévisions retransmettra le
tournoi des six nations avec l'arrivée
de l'italie l'an prochain france
télévisions retransmettra également les
test matches des meilleures nations de
l'hémisphère sud disputé dans l'hexagone
c'est dire la responsabilité lourde que
l'on prend avec france télévisions et
puis le souci de france télévisions
d'être avec nous des véritables
partenaires pour cette équipe de france
qui a besoin de développer son image de
développer sa sas à sa capacité à
triompher sur l'ensemble des terrains du
monde après le retrait de tf1 france
télévisions était en compétition avec m6
le service public l'a emporté à
l'unanimité moins une voix
nous arrivons à la fin de ce journal je
vous rappelle deux informations tout
d'abord concernant la corse les
gendarmes mis en examen resteront en
prison au moins deux d'entre eux dont le
colonel a décidé de juger un premier
rapport d'enquêté administratif doit
être remis avant la fin de la semaine
les frappes intensives de l'otan à
belgrade au kosovo et au monténégro
encore et puis monsieur ibérique était
l'invitée cette édition après que les
efforts diplomatiques continuent elles
et qu'ils étaient en attente du
déplacement de monsieur tchernomyrdine
tellement à belgrade mais pas de pause
dans les frappes a bien dit monsieur
védrine dans quelques secondes la météo
de ce fidèlement suivi du point route de
valérie maurice et puis donc envoyé
spécial avec notamment le document sur
la vie quotidienne à belgrade de jacques
merino à 23h10 qu'accorderait d'un film
avec clint eastwood le dernier journal
où sera présenté à 1h15 par florence
duprat suivi de la 25e heure de jacques
perrin demain à 7h50 dans les 4 vérités
françoise laborde recevra madame nicole
notât et puis à 13h vous retrouverez
rachid arhab et à 20h des tricheurs berg
à lundi bonsoir merci
autre